and the Ravens quarterback lamar jackson
who joins us on the program lamar how
are you today I'm doing okay how did you
feel after your first game physically
great and we came out with it mentally I
came we came out great wonderful but you
ran the ball an awful lot 27 times
did you get hit that's about it
but do you practice sliding I don't okay
but you've been taught you didn't play
baseball growing up did you no I did it
but you got to protect yourself
absolutely right you're right okay what
are you making sure you're protecting
yourself absolutely not
when they come but you know arm had to
do what we had to do to win this game
but you know throughout the season you
know it won't take 27 verses or whatever
it was yeah but Lamar feels like I'm
more worried about you than you are and
I you know we went over a lot of pass
ups no so we wasn't able to you know get
that out in the game Sunday but this
week I'm you know got Oakland so we'll
go from there what does your mom say
does she worry about you out there
she was worried about intercession I
threw the secret ich your game when I'm
doing you know when I'm not performing
well or if I make mistakes out there
mental mistakes or you know just you
know just mistake what about me
sometimes she's always on my clothes too
so she does are you starting against the
Raiders ever heard yeah okay do you know
but you can't tell me no I don't know
actually I really don't know who but you
should be starting I would think
hopefully okay alright yeah I didn't
know I didn't know if Joe Flacco is
healthy
first of all but what is the difference
between college at Louisville and the
pros like the biggest difference that
you saw this past weekend um everyone
runs to the ball you know in the lead
that's the difference between college
because if you go back and college from
you can see guys you know take a break
some plays and stuff like that but you
know and the league is all 11 at ball
every single play it's not one guy
taking a break you know you're out there
so that's the biggest thing I've seen
like you know performing on Phil did you
get any tax tweets anybody send you
anything nice is somebody giving you
grief they're do-don do-don over there
you need to start up oh who did you hear
from after your game anybody surprising
give you a text or tweet wait you know
there's no friends to say hey Congrats a
lot of people did you know a lot of
people did my phone was long are some
people I couldn't get back you know in
touch with after the game because my
phone was dead
but there was a lot of people yeah yeah
where's the Heisman Trophy
I haven't home oh you're home not your
mom's yeah oh that's nice do you bring
it in did you bring it in and put it in
your locker with let though your
teammates it did they haze you did they
make you do anything fun your rookie see
oh no they did I love you wait why
didn't they do that they gotta make some
100 we had this rookie you know we had
to do this little Ricky thing and we had
to get on stage and perform it from the
whole team without any instrumentals had
to sing so yeah what'd you sing that
song no flaw cannot change it to I
changed it to let me hear it let me hear
a little bit no it's not appropriate
your mom would be proud that you just
said that that's a good thing
Congrats so far hopefully we get a
chance see again against the Raiders and
many more after that but congratulated
talk to you again Thank You Lamar
there's no problem let's sell Lamar
Jackson Ravens rookie quarterback for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]